That argument went out the window. What
about you can't see God? You know,
you're God and you're telling me that
God became a man and all right, let's
read what he conveniently
left out. Now, let's see. Okay.
Okay. Let's go right here. Let's see.
He's quoting Exodus 33:20. But hold on,
my friend. Hello, darkness, my old
friend. Why don't you read the entirety?
Let's see what Exodus 33 actually says.
All right, let's read Exodus 33:7-11.
Now Moses used to take the tent and
pitch it outside the camp, a good
distance from the camp. And he called it
the tent of meeting, and everyone who
sought Yahweh would go out to the tent
of meeting, which was outside the camp.
And it happened whenever Moses went out
to the tent, that all the people would
rise and stand each at the entrance of
his tent, and gaze after Moses.
Right, let me do this. gave after Moses.
Now why? They would look what what Moses
is doing
until he entered the tent. And it
happened whenever Moses entered the tent
and that the pillar of cloud would
descend and stand at the entrance of the
tent and Yahweh would speak with Moses.
Yahweh would speak with Moses and the
people would see the pillar of cloud
standing at the entrance of the tent and
all the people would arise and worship
each at the entrance of his tent. Then
Yahweh used to speak to Moses face to
face directly.
The language face to face means that God
spoke personally to Moses directly and
didn't use an angelic creature. No
agent, no angelic medium. He spoke to
him directly. He appeared to him
directly just as a man speaks to his
friend.
[clears throat] Then Moses returned to
the camp and his tenant Joshua the son
of Non, a young man would not depart
from the tent. Okay. Now, note why he
entered the tent. Cuz when the pillar
cloud came down, that's when Yahweh
would meet him between the cherubam by
the mercy seat. And then Yahweh and
Moses would speak directly mouthto
mouth, face to face,
right? Something he did not allow the
rest of the Israelites to see. Exodus 24
9-15 9-18, I'm sorry. Then
[clears throat] Moses went up with
Aaron, Naab, Abaiu, and the 70 elders of
Israel. They saw the God of Israel
under his feet. Oh, so God appeared with
feet. There appeared to be a pavement of
sapphire. So they're seeing God at a
close enough distance in a visible form,
visible shape. And they see his feet
writing what looked like pavement as
clear as the sky itself. Yet he did not
stretch out his hand against the nobles
of the sons of Israel. And they beheld
God and they ate and drank. Now notice
this is on the earth. They're saying
this
in this earth in this world
because he's saying not in this world,
not in the material world. Really?
All right. Yet he did not stretch out
his hand against the noble sons because
they thought seeing God would bring
instant death. instantaneous death. No,
God at mercy. He allowed them to see a
glimpse of him without killing them.
They beheld God. They ate and drank. Now
watch the difference with Moses. They
could see God at a glance visibly. Moses
entered the cloud, stood before God face
to face, and saw his visible form. How
do I know?
Now, when Yahweh Now, Yahweh said to,
and by the way, this is all in my
series, Trinity in the Old Testament.
Angel of the Lord in the Old Testament
in the playlists. Now Yahweh
said to Moses, "Come up to me on the
mountain, remain there, and I will give
you the stone tablets with the law and
the commandment which I have written for
their instruction." So Moses arose with
Joshua's attendant. And Moses went up to
the mountain of God. But to the elders
he said, "Remain here for us until we
return to you. And behold, Aaron and her
are with you. Whoever has a legal
matter, let him approach them. Then
Moses went up to the mountain. The cloud
covered the mountain. The
[clears throat] glory of Yahweh dwelt on
Mount Sai.
And the cloud covered for six days. And
on the seventh day, the day of rest,
symbolic here. You want true rest. You
can only experience true rest in God's
presence. Enter the presence of God. Be
filled with the presence of God. If you
want to experience Sabbath, he called it
to Moses in the midst of the cloud.
[clears throat] And the appearance of
the glory of Yahweh was like a consuming
fire in the mountain top. So the people
in the wilderness, they saw a pillar of
cloud. They saw fire, smoke, and they
heard thunder. That's all they saw in
the eyes of the sons of Israel. Then
Moses entered the midst of the cloud as
he went up to the mountain. And Moses
was on the mountain 40 days and 40
nights. All right, let's go right here.
Let me do this. Let me add a couple more
verses. Numbers 12:48. What did Moses
see in the cloud? What did he behold?
Suddenly Yahweh said to Moses and Aaron
to Miriam, you three come out to the
tent of meaning. So the three of them
came out. Then Yahweh came down in a
pillar of cloud and stood at the doorway
of the tent. He called Aaron and Miriam.
And then both came forward and he said,
notice again pillar cloud at the tent
where Moses would enter and speak to God
face to face. [clears throat] Hear now
my words. If there is a prophet among
you, I Yahweh shall speak shall make
myself known to him in a vision. I shall
speak within a dream. In other words, I
will allow a prophet to see me in a
dream and vision. But for Moses, I took
it one step further. I appear on earth
And I came down to the earth to meet
with him personally. See the honor he
gave to Moses. Not so with my servant
Moses. He is faithful in all my
household. With him I speak mouthto
mouth directly.
Indeed clearly not in riddles. I don't
speak parables. I make my will clear to
him. And he be beholds the form of
Yahweh.
Why did he quote this and not quote the
context?
That the same Moses says God appeared to
him visibly in a form which he could
see, spoke to him directly. So, what is
he talking about?
All right. Well, still not convinced.
Let's now read the passage he butchered.
You cannot see my face. Let's go back
up. Let's read the context.
This is after we're told in the same
context here,
right here. Thus, Yahweh used to speak
to Moses face to face just as a man
speaks to his friend. Then Moses would
return to the camp and as a ten of
Joshua son of Nun, a young man would not
depart from the tent. Notice what face
to face means. I appear to him directly.
Face to face speak to him mouthto mouth.
That's when he sees my form.
Right.
Numbers 128.
All right.
He speaks to him face to face as a man
speaks to his friend. Now let's see what
the context is. Exodus 33:18-23.
[clears throat] They rarely quote the
context. Then Moses said, "I pray you,
show me your glory." They said, "I
myself will make all my goodness pass
before you, and I will proclaim the name
of Yahweh before you, and I'll be
gracious to whom I'll be gracious, and I
will show compassion on whom I will show
compassion." But he said, "You cannot
see my face, for no man can see me and
live." Okay, that's what he just quoted.
Then Yahweh said, "Behold, there's a
place by me. You shall stand there on
the rock,
and it will come about while my glory is
passing by that I'll put you in the
cliff of the rock and cover you with my
hand until I pass by. Then I'll remove
my hand. You will see my back, but my
face shall not be seen." Why didn't he
quote the rest of it? God did not say
Moses cannot see him at all. God said,
"You'll see my back but not my face."
So why did he quote that?
The very passage,
the very I hope you're doing good. You
said you're cancer free that says you'll
not see God's face as you can see his
back. Now, I'm going to explain the
metaphor. And by the way, notice why
he's able to see
see
the back of Moses. He first has to be
planted on the rock.
He has to be planted on the rock in the
rock. So, the rock keeps him stable,
right? And the hand of the Lord has to
be upon him. Well, if you want to take
it in a deep spiritual manner, the rock
is Christ and the hand of the Lord is
Christ. In other words, you need to be
in Christ, built on Christ in order to
be able to see God in any sense because
he's the rock. He's the arm of Yahweh.
He's the hand of the Lord.
You got it?
If you want to take it on that level of
spiritual
application.
Yep. You didn't know that words. In
Isaiah 53:1 and2, Jesus is said to be
the arm of Yahweh, Yahweh,
something even the fathers acknowledge.
And he's the rock. So, how do you see
God? by being built solidly upon the
rock, clefting in the rock and union at
the rock. And because of your union with
the rock, you'll be able to see God
[whistles]
whisper. You guys are all asleep, huh?
All right. Here. No one has seen God.
John 1:18. At any time, the only
begotten God who's in the bosom of the
father, he has explained them. Without
Jesus, you cannot see God, perceive God,
know God, understand God. Right? He's in
the father's heart. Well, who's the
rock? 1 Corinthians 10:104.
Who's that rock that God will place
Moses on, right? Cleft him in that rock.
So that be
in that rock, united to that rock,
clinging to that rock,
which enables him to then see God. Here
1 Corinthians 10:4.
For I do not want you to be unaware,
brothers, that our fathers were all
under the cloud, notice the cloud, what
were we talking about? Pillar cloud, and
all passed through the sea, and all were
baptized into Moses. There's Moses in
the cloud and the sea. And all ate the
same spiritual food. Who provide to
them? provided for them supernaturally.
Spiritual means supernaturally, mana
from heaven, quailes, water
[clears throat] from a rock, and all
drank the same spiritual drink. For they
were drinking from a spiritual rock
which followed them. And the rock was
Christ.
Right. The rock was Christ. And who's
the hand? The arm of Yahweh.
Isaiah 53:12 talking about the servant
who will die for our sins who has
believed our report and to whom whom has
the arm of Yahweh been revealed for he
grew up before him notice the he that
grew up is the arm he the arm grew
before Yahweh and this is about the
servant who dies for our sins that's
Jesus so the arm hand of Yahweh the
father Jesus the spiritual rock that was
with Moses and the Israelites Jesus. And
without Jesus, you cannot see, perceive,
understand God.
So God says, "I'm going to have to place
you on the rock
in the rock."
So the rock keeps you stable, and that
rock will then enable you to see my back
when I remove my hand. Meaning I unveil
myself with my hand right being removed.
You got it.
But let's come back to the point.
Did Exodus 33 say you can't see God at
all?
Is that what it said?
Did Exodus 33:20 say you can't see God
at all?
Or does it say you can't see his face,
but you will see my back?
So, does this passage show you can see
God in some sense? So, what does it
mean? If God is not a physical being, he
doesn't literally have a physical face
or physical back. What does that mean?
What does that mean?
Well, when you speak of the face, you
see someone clearly. If you see my face,
you're seeing me clearly. But if you see
my back, you know it's me, but you don't
see me clearly, right? So, what Moses is
saying is, I want to see a greater
manifestation of your glory from what
you're showing me. I want to see your
glory displayed visibly
the way it's displayed in heaven in all
its fullness. When God manifests the
fullness of his glory so that you can
see him in a visible form, right? That's
what they behold in heaven.
I want to see that more of that. God
says, "Well, I cannot manifest the
fullness of my glory
the way it's displayed in heaven
because it'll be too much for you. But
I'll give you
a greater display. I'll let you see more
of it. I'll let you see my back."
You understand?
That's the point.
So the very passage he cited proved that
he's lying.
This passage did not say God cannot be
seen. The same Moses says God is seen.
He saw his form and he saw a greater
display of his glory because in heaven
he manifests his glory in all its
fullness. Meaning he appears in a
visible manner where you see his
radiance
which is something Moses wanted to see
on earth but God says that's too much
for you to handle. So, I'll let you see
a little more.
I've been through these passages in my
series on the Trinity, Old Testament,
and the angel of Yahweh.
Okay, we got now how not only does he
not know Islam, he doesn't know
Christianity. Now I expect them not to
know Christianity.